después de seis años por fin vuelve a
casa el gobierno británico anunció el
miércoles que la ciudadana británico
iraní nazanín sagar it life fue liberada
de la detención y podía regresar al
reino unido es el mismo caso que el del
también detenido a anisya sur y los
medios de comunicación iraníes dijeron
que reino unido había pagado una deuda
de 525 millones de dólares que se
remonta al sha de irán
podemos dejar de ser un momento de la
historia y volver a ser una familia
normal si ha pasado mucho tiempo no ha
sido un largo viaje que la gente ha
seguido en las noticias en las
peticiones con el gobierno he dicho
cosas muy duras a lo largo de los años
pero al final va a volver a casa
ambos poseedores de la doble
nacionalidad habían sido detenidos
acusados de conspirar para derrocar al
gobierno iraní en 2016 sagrat life
trabajaba como directora de proyectos
para la fundación thomson reuters
estaban en el aeropuerto de teherán con
su hija pequeña cuando fue detenida
repentinamente pese a negar los cargos
fue declarada culpable y condenada a 5
años de prisión el esposo de zsa caridad
plate richard ha presionado al gobierno
durante varios años para conseguir su
liberación
llegando a realizar una huelga de hambre
de tres semanas ambas familias han
argumentado que estaban retenidos como
presos políticos convirtiéndose en
moneda de cambio entre irán y reino
unido- en medio de las crecientes
tensiones internacionales pero desde
londres lo rechazan
hemos trabajado duro durante los últimos
seis meses para asegurar la liberación
de estos detenidos sólo quiero decir que
mis condolencias están con las familias
por lo que han sufrido en este tiempo
atroz
un tercer ciudadano con doble
nacionalidad morata bas también fue
liberado pero todavía no podrá regresar
al reino unido